hey guys it's Justine and today we're
gonna do a video that nobody asked for
but everyone needs we are going to be
doing an iPhone 11 Pro max verse the new
2020 iPhone se vers iPad pro 2028 camera
test thank you to be brand for
sponsoring this video we have some black
camo skins going to deck out my iPhone's
and my iPad and this is one of their
grip cases its protective its grippy it
also has very clicky buttons you can
also customize the skins this case is
impact resistant up to 9 feet and we all
know how I am with my phones I need this
check out the link in the description to
get your own case or skins from deep
brands website let's put on these skins
and start this camera test
[Music]
finn set up a little it's really great
I'm working on a mac pro upgrade video
so I'm gonna take a few photos here of
the setup and then I'll show you guys
what that looks like
so first photo now let's test out the
video this is 4k 30 on all three cameras
are you ready here we got our testing
out the video on the back facing camera
on all three of these devices we've got
the iPad 2 the iPhone of the Promax
and the iPhone se 20/20 I don't know
what it looks like right now but I'm
here do you guys want to see what 1.5
terabytes of RAM looks like my heart now
gonna set it seven second timer and see
if I can get a great timer photo at the
same time with all of these I tried to
look at the middle so you can tell on
movie iPad that I'm clearly not looking
at the iPad let's check out the front
facing cameras the lighting is much
better this way from basing tests
complete let me show you what the
wide-angle selfie looks like compared to
but not wide-angle selfie only iPhone se
[Music]
so the iPad can actually do a
front-facing portrait mode so I'm gonna
go through and do front-facing portrait
on each one of these but first the iPad
[Music]
okay same pose every single time I only
have one face all I can do
it's so weird looking at the iPad front
facing camera because it actually looks
like I'm looking in a mirror
I could probably probably use this for
makeup application if I didn't have a
mirror like in a hotel or something oh
it definitely could eyeliner this is
massive I don't think that I like seeing
my face up this close you guys probably
don't either I'm so sorry
now a front-facing video so the only one
that is 4k is the iPhone Pro max which
is you right here the rest are 1080 so
here's our iPad
hello iPad how are you hello iPhone se
how are you let me show you guys my
friends this is Tom Nook he's a thief
and here's cake a slider he's a very
talented musician hey guys don't know
him you need to get to know it so I
couldn't find any of my juggling balls
but I did just get some Mac Pro wheels
so I thought that I would juggle these
in slow-mo for you I would like to note
these are really heavy nervous
[Music]
feel that you're supposed to put onto
the tower jams into your hand now let's
test out portrait mode on the iPhone se
and the iPhone 11 pro max the iPad
doesn't have rear-facing portrait mode
so we're just gonna test it out on these
two are are you ready slider
[Music]
my findings and a bigger screen now we
need to take one with the iPad a thing
is so I'm gonna take a mirror selfie
because it's 2005 and I'm on MySpace so
I'm gonna set a timer I'm super into a
10 second timer I never used to set
timers what I would take that back in
the day but I also wasn't taking them
with three different devices Oh God I'm
walking back into my space for this this
needs to be seen eventually one more
because I feel like why not I feel like
one of these photos is probably the same
size as my hard drive back in 2005 so
let's really just go for it for sure one
of the biggest requests that I got on my
iPhone se challenge video is you guys
wanted to see what it looks like when
you take photos at night now this
doesn't have night mode but the iPhone
11 Pro max does so I'll show you guys
what it looks like with night mode on
and off compared to the iPhone se and of
course the iPad which also doesn't have
night mode iPad photography 101 I
brought this actually is a flash how
cool do I look with the iPad and an iPad
a flash look at this I can like put it
on my shoulder and like a news anchor
[Music]
that my friends concludes our night
camera test back you just seen in the
bathroom video just do a little test
between all three of these devices
because why not I look forward to being
able to leave the house to do camera and
photo tests for you but in the meantime
I got a tweet I will say I've definitely
enjoyed having it touch the home button
again quite nice I'll see you in my next
video
have a good weekend or a weekday or
weekend even a thing anymore I think
every day is just a day
[Music]